diese ohrfeige die wir ihnen gleich
zeigen werden hat am samstagabend ganz
deutschland erschüttert am rande des
boxkampfes von felix sturm in der
dortmunder westfalenhalle attackiert ein
mann völlig unvermittelt den comedian
oliver pocher der täter nennt sich fett
comedy heißt mit bürgerlichem namen oma
und ist rapper und internet komiker für
woche kamen die klatsche wirklich aus
dem nichts er blieb bei bewusstsein zum
glück sprang auf und konnte fliehen
jetzt holt der komiker zum gegenschlag
aus und zwar mit der vollen härte des
gesetzes in einem 13 minütigen statement
sz oliver pocher heute unter anderem
dass er gegen diesen angeblichen
comedian und rapper anzeige erstattet
hat wegen körperverletzung drei weitere
wichtige aussagen des entertainers
wollen wir ihnen jetzt einmal zeigen
können da mal rein
ich habe jetzt ein tagebuch ehrlich
gesagt damit verbracht das einmal beim
arzt zu sein und ich finde auch gar
nicht der comedy aspekten ein bisschen
auf achtung hört auch wortspiel denn man
muss auch ziemlich angeschlagen gewesen
und
wenn ich pech habe habe ich ihre parade
schäden die nicht wieder zurückgehen
muss montagen der behandlung machen wir
versuchen das einigermaßen wieder in den
griff zu bekommen aber ich kann momentan
gewisse frequenz
frequenzbereiche einfach nicht hören für
so eine kleine backpfeife für was auch
immer naja diese kleine backpfeife die
eben ganz schöne konsequenzen mit sich
gezogen hat darüber möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit bild live show chefin
giannina kirsch die wir bei mir im
studio ist italiener hatte ich das
gewundert dass oliver pocher jetzt so
ein langes statement vor allem jetzt
auch veröffentlicht hat oli pocher ist
ja dafür bekannt dass er seinen
instagram kanal für alles nutzt gibt ihr
die bekannte bildschirm kontrolle wo er
sich auch gerne mal über menschen lustig
macht aber er nutzt das auch als kanal
für sich für für viele dinge also auch
als die ukraine krise losgingen der
krieg in der ukraine hatte das genutzt
um dort auf die problematik aufmerksam
zu machen also das ist sein kanal
deswegen hat es mich überhaupt nicht
gewundert ich finde es super dass es
gemacht hat weil er wirklich in voller
härte da jetzt auch drüber gesprochen
hat er hat diese attacke als
hinterhältig und feige bezeichnet und
nichts anderes war ist und ich habe es
vorhin schon gesagt fährt comedy hat
ehrlicherweise nur von hier bis zu
seinem nächsten zehnagel gedacht denn
zum ersten licht nicht in der lage wären
jeder weiß dass wenn man so etwas tut
dass das dann auch konsequenzen
körperliche konsequenzen für den anderen
haben kann wir haben es gerade gehört
olli hört gewisse sequenzen nicht und
das kann natürlich auch strafrechtlich
ganz böse für familien ausgehen haben ja
dazu mit einer ärzten gesprochen die
eben dazu nochmal einmal ihre
einschätzung gegeben hat wie es ja wie
ist oliver pocher jetzt genau ging wir
haben mit boxweltmeister mit kickbox
weltmeisterin und ärztin dr christine
theiss gesprochen
die wahl bei uns in bayern sagt für
oliver pocher war natürlich nicht
harmlos warum weil oliver pocher sie
nicht hat kommen sehen das heißt der
körper konnte sich überhaupt nicht auf
das vorbereiten was sie da erwartet
keinerlei abwehrreaktion und es können
alle beteiligten nur froh sein dass
oliver pocher nicht gestürzt ist und mit
dem kopf irgendwo hingeknallt ist weil
dann hätte das ganze ganz anders ausging
aber auch ohne diese schwerwiegenden
folge kann ein schlag mit der flachen
hand auf das schwere verletzung und
inneren des ohres auslösen das ist alles
andere als ein kavaliersdelikt
ja wirklich wahnsinn was so eine
backpfeife eben auslösen kann finde ich
ganz spannend den aspekt dass sie sagt
dass es natürlich und sie spricht als
kickbox-weltmeisterin was anderes ist
wenn du vorbereitet bist auf einen
schlag und dich körperlich auch
anspannen kannst das hat er halt nicht
also es war wirklich ein hinterhalt ja
und auch zum thema happy slapping und
zum thema mittäterschaft hat sich pocher
ja geäußert in seinen augen sind nämlich
die menschen die solche videos
beklatschen mindestens genauso schuldig
und leuten die das jetzt beklatschen
gerade auch aus der deutsch rap und hip
hop szene
die sind mittäter ich glaube stellen
sich ja auch nicht hin dass um
vergewaltigung video und sagen
vielleicht haben die alte das ja geil
das ist nämlich genau das was in dieser
form da stattfindet und ins happy
slapping was ja auch dadurch sogar einen
namen mittlerweile hat viele können sich
dann wehren vielen passiert das
tagtäglich in der schule oder irgendwo
anders und das war jetzt ein
präzedenzfall bei einer öffentlichen
veranstaltung in der ersten reihe ja
damit macht oliver pocher eben das was
ihm passiert ist auch wirklich zum
gesellschaftspolitischen thema absolut
absolut er hatte da auch einen schönen
vergleich stellen wir uns das vor jemand
steht auf dem schulhof verprügelt jemand
anders unterstehen kinder drumherum und
fangen an zu klatschen natürlich sind
das irgendwie mittäter wenn sie dann
nicht hilfe holen und auch darüber haben
wir gesprochen mit der familie
psychologin ina zeremonie am rhein
diese skurrile trend happy slapping
bringt nur auch vermehrt sich natürlich
und zuallererst die betroffenen selbst
aber auch die zuschauer aus zwei gründen
entweder sie bekommen ein schlechtes
modell ein falsches idol und das ist in
meinen augen des redens daran dass
gerade aus der erwachsenenwelt in die
öffentlichkeit hinein getragen wird oder
aber sie würden den betroffenen
eigentlich gerne helfen wissen aber
nicht wie das heißt sie erleben sich
selbst als nicht wirksam und das ist
kein guter prädiktor für ein glückliches
leben so die größten opfer sind in
meinen augen aber immer die täter weil
ihr verhalten hat einen grund und
deswegen brauchen sie in meinen augen
vor allem eins hilfe
ich bin super dankbar dass oliver pocher
seine prominenz dafür nutzt um auf einen
missstand aufmerksam zu machen denn er
hat etwas was die meisten opfer
systematischer gewalt nicht mehr haben
ein gesundes selbstbewusstsein und
oliver pocher will jetzt auch juristisch
gegen seinen angreifer vorgehen was er
dazu genau gesagt hat da haben wir auch
an rhein und das werden wir vor gericht
und mit allen mitteln in der nächsten
zeit klären und ich hoffe auf eine
maximale strafe auch mit aktueller
wirkungen das am meisten abschreckt ist
in dem man einfach erst mal alle social
media accounts verliert 100 lustig
irgendwo auf dem handy zahlen können
dann guck mal was mir passiert ist ist
das nicht wahnsinnig lustig gewesen nein
war es nicht aber trotzdem ich komme da
raus aus der nummer ich will auch weiter
auftreten ich halt auch weiter sachen
sagen die manche leute unangenehm oder
nicht lustig bin ja wenn der social
media account von ebendiesem rapper
beziehungsweise comedian gesperrt werden
würde da würde er wahrscheinlich
wirklich sich sehr ärgern aber schon
dafür wie realistisch ist das ja das ist
das eine also instagram zu sperren wäre
schon mal der erste schritt aber uli
geht halt noch viel weiter olli sagt er
gibt nicht auf und er will alles dafür
tun dass dieser mann die konsequenzen
spürt auch strafrechtlich er sogar davon
gesprochen dass er ihn in knast bringen
möchte am liebsten er sagte so einen
satz wie na dann geht er im zweifel da
hin wo man ihnen dann nicht mehr nur
noch die augen küs und auch eine
geldstrafe steht natürlich im raum und
oliver hat aber auch gesagt wenn es eine
strafe geben sollte also eher geld sein
muss dann würde er das nicht für sich
verwenden sondern würde natürlich einen
guten zweck finden also es ist eine
knallharte kampfansage von oliver pocher
gegen fett comedy und wir haben mit
einem der bekanntesten deutschen
strafrechtler gesprochen burkhard
benecken und der hat uns mal
eingeschätzt der wie gut die chancen von
oliver pocher eigentlich stehen
strafrechtlich könnte das was oliver
pocher passiert ist eine gefährliche
körperverletzung sein denn das könnte
durchaus ein hinterlistiger überfalls an
dieser schlag von der seite und
natürlich auch eine lebensgefährten eine
behandlung dann läge eine mindeststrafe
von sechs monaten und eine höchststrafe
von bis zu zehn jahren vor aber selbst
wenn man das ganze nur als einfache
körperverletzung werden würde glaube ich
ganz sicher dass die deutsche
strafjustiz ist hier mit aller härte
vorgehen wird denn dass es eine
besonders unschöne tat wenn man vorher
schon plant jemanden den man schlägt
dann im netz noch zu demütigen ist das
happy slapping und das ist wirklich ganz
übel und er kennt die strafjustiz keinen
spaß ja die strafjustiz kennt keinen
spaß janina was meinst du denn wie geht
es da jetzt weiter also olli wird alles
dafür tun dass anwälte
sich staatsanwaltschaft sich mit pferd
comedy an einen tisch setzen und da ein
möglichst hohes strafmaß kommt wir haben
eben auch nochmal burkhard benecken
nachgefragt und gesagt wie sieht es denn
aus mit schadensersatz weil es ist
natürlich strafrechtlich dass eine
zivilrechtlich das andere das muss man
halt im deutschen recht immer
unterscheiden aber er hat uns dann auch
gesagt da bestehen super gute chancen
dass der schadensersatz gezahlt werden
muss und ich finde auch zu recht weil
ganz ehrlich so eine brutalität
rechtfertigt wirklich gar nichts also
wirklich einfach es gibt keine
rechtfertigung für so eine gewalt es war
ein hinterhalt und er muss auch in
meinen augen höchstmöglich bestraft
werden zumal die gründe dafür ja auch
ziemlich absurd waren es gab es ging
darum dass oliver pocher eine frau
irgendwie sympathisiert hat die
irgendwie gegen den freund des comedians
es gibt einen rapper heißt sandra
relativ bekannt in der deutschen
rap-szene und dem wurde vergewaltigung
vorgeworfen von einer influenza rinn und
oliver pocher und amira seine frau haben
in ihrem gemeinsamen podcast sympathie
mit dieser frau gezeigt und sandra also
der beschuldigte ist ein freund von fett
comedy und das war quasi der angebliche
grund dafür völlig irre also noch weiter
hergeholt kann so ein grund für so eine
ohrfeige überhaupt gar nicht sein und
meinen augen wollte der einfach seinen
moment nutzen um irgendwie seine
bekanntheit weil kein mensch kennt fährt
comedy zu steigern und das ist ihm
gelungen auf eine sehr tragische art und
weise aber dafür hat er auch sehr viel
verbrannte erde hinterlassen und mit ihm
werden über ihn werden wir nur noch im
negativen kontext berichten